just clearing the throat because this
first name is a biggie one tall drink of
water Virginia
Elizabeth Gina Davis
Geena Davis is an artist of grand
quality and great achievement she is
hilarious in person she is delightful at
a distance and even better up close did
you know she is an Olympic level athlete
literally an Olympic level quality
athlete and Archer she is as sure eyed
and masterly of the ball and arrow as is
the goddess hunter Diana herself in
other words do not cross Geena Davis
she has entertained thrilled and made
millions of moviegoers fall in love with
her just as she has worked for the
enlightenment of our society supporting
causes worthy and necessary most
specifically for tonight and for the
next 300 years perhaps her
groundbreaking efforts to bring about
awareness of gender bias in order to
halt such box
who then better to kick off her being
honored with the Jean Hersholt award
then a white guy who's been on the cover
of the AARP magazine back in 1992 Gina
and about 600 other women and one guy
one guy starred in a film focus directly
on gender bias it was a league of their
own directed by the late great Penny
Marshall
Gina's character was called Dottie
Hinson Dottie and she was playing
baseball for an all women's baseball
league during Second World War
Dottie had to contend with a vastly
unequal position of women at the time
and perhaps even worse
Dottie had to contend with the actor who
played her reluctant male manager Jimmy
Dugan now the first time Jimmy Dugan
speaks directly to Dottie
Judah's character fifty four minutes of
the film has gone by Dottie is in the
third-base coach coaching box and she's
sending signals to the lineup the
Rockford peaches as they come up to bat
and she is asked about her strategy and
abilities by her male manager Jimmy
Dugan with this line hey what are you
stupid
now that particular line might have been
about baseball but it was certainly
filtered through the topic of gender
bias Dottie was signaling the peaches to
her best hitter to squeeze bunt when
clearly she should have been telling her
to swing away now is Dottie Hinson
giving the wrong signal because she
didn't know baseball or was Dottie
giving the wrong signal because as a
girl there is no way she could have
known baseball now throughout the film
Dottie Hinson makes her presence and
power and her strength known their
confidence her self-awareness or humor
and yes her baseball prowess very much
like
Gina herself the baseball prowess of
course being the punchline to that joke
she's an archer ladies and gentlemen of
Olympic quality Virginia Elizabeth Davis
has an abundance of the very best
qualities in a human being can share
with others throughout her career she's
chosen roles that show women is complet
characters and control of their own
destiny Thelma and Louise for crying out
loud
her ethics her principles her sense of
what is right and what is wrong as
demonstrated in all of her work led
maybe to her turning the same sort of
focus that she gives to her bow and
arrow and her artistic choices on to the
a social imperative which is to change
the landscape of media to reflect an
accurate gender balance diverse
portrayal of society after all numbers
do not lie the world is peopled with the
exact same ratio as women to men it's
5050 so why isn't the media the same
[Music]
Gina posits that question and Gina wants
an answer Gina and do you know what Gina
wants Gina gets the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award is given to quote an
individual in the motion picture arts
and sciences whose humanitarian efforts
have brought credit to the industry so
is there a better example of that than
creating an entire organization
dedicated to providing young girls with
examples of women on screen who are
smart who are resilient who are
hardworking who are inspiring who are
instinctively talented and who are
actually played by women who are
employed in the business of show now not
to mansplain Gina's commitment to gender
equality and by that I mean when a man
our articulates specifically and in less
confusing language how bales can
sometimes Oh what is it make themselves
the expert in a certain topic as a
grandfather of three little girls who
given a fair shake
thanks to Geena Davis will follow their
natural and inclinations to make the
world a better place for all of
humankind as they grow up
I thank Gina for a work on their behalf
and I joined with the governors and all
the rest of the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences
[Music]
in celebrating celebrated and honoring
her with tonight's Jean Hersholt award
ladies and gentlemen let's look at the
glorious work of one of the finest human
beings I've ever had the pleasure to
know work with and live not too close
away from the choices that are
demonstrated by one Virginia
Elizabeth Gina Davis